anyway here with reaction the author of
the best-selling book vengeance former
Speaker of the House Fox News
contributor Newt Gingrich you're
laughing I'm laughing too I forgot I
forgot the good old days there is some
truth in what he's saying in this regard
I think we have a series of scandals and
looking at Devon Nunez today that the
abuse of government surveillance by the
FBI is so bad and all that we're
uncovering here is so bad he's right the
mainstream media you know they just they
want to destroy Trump and they loved him
it's that simple
look you know know each other a long
time so I'm gonna spend some of your
money why don't you offer $100,000 to
create the Barack Obama Fox News Sean
Hannity scholarship if he will come on
the show with you that is such a funny
look that's such a funny segment I'm
just telling you I bet I listen to it I
thought to myself this guy is so whacked
today I mean he still doesn't get it
I'll never get it look many many years
from now in a nursing home or a nice
retirement community Barack Obama will
be still living in a fantasy life he'll
think that Iran should really wanted to
have a deal he'll think that high taxes
really work he'll think that welfare is
a good deal I mean but you just put
together is as I think funny a statement
of who Barack Obama is as I've ever seen
and it captures this this sense of being
out of touch with reality let's talk
about the media in this sense they spent
a year mr. speaker there's no evidence
of Trump Russia collusion we play the
montage the Democrats saying there's no
evidence of collusion
and yet we do have evidence of
unbelievable instance of abusing the
weapons of intelligence and surveilling
masking and leaking raw intelligence we
know that the fix was in with Hillary
and Bernie
we know that the fix was in Comey and
struck rigged they had an exoneration
before even an investigation we know
that Hillary paid for a dossier full of
Russian propaganda
we know that dossier now was used to get
FISA warrants to spy on an opposition
candidate and a president-elect and his
team and I'm not even talking about
uranium one or Debbie wasserman-schultz
there seems to be there are two
realities here and the media has chosen
a reality of partisanship and conspiracy
theories either that or I'm wrong but
they didn't think Trump can win and
people like you and me were right look
what you have to understand I'm actually
working in a book called Trump's America
trying to explain this because it's so
it is so unbelievably hard to understand
if you're a normal person over here is a
left-wing corrupt establishment which
sincerely sees this entire fight as a
function of identity politics in which
if they lose they will disappear over
here are the rest of us who are thinking
you know a lot of these ideas are really
weird I mean Obama thought if you gave a
hundred billion dollars to Iran they'd
be nice people Obama thought it was
terrific that we had more people on food
stamps than ever before you get a whole
list of these things and this is really
a definition of life and death and so
what you and I are living through is a
period where the old order the
establishment that inherited and then
this is important ascend they inherited
Walter Cronkite the inherited Eduardo
they inherited the old Harvard and then
hair did all these great centers of
authority and it's
possibility and they have gradually
turned them into left wing nut cake
positions and so the truth is we're not
entity fight in which if we win they
disappear if they win we disappear
that's why what you and I experience
because we're great friends were great
warriors in the same cause and we both
understand if we lose we will literally
disappear on the other hand if we win
America will continue to move forward as
the freest country in the world why and
I think that's why both of us fight that
you're describing it perfectly to be
honest though at least nobody I think
really wants to know what truly
motivates us but that's a separate issue
but as a practical matter I I can I can
shoot off a litany of Obama statistics
and what does true record is on the
economy you mentioned Iran you think you
can bribe murdering thugs dictators and
you know not mention radical Islamic
terrorism and then in a year of Trump
you can compare policy significant
changes with tangible results but the
media won't talk about any of it look
you would think if Barack Obama was a
sincere person who genuinely cared about
African Americans when you've got a
report this week that we have the lowest
black unemployment in years because the
economy is starting to work Trump's cut
tax cuts regulatory cuts pro-business
attitude it's starting north
you'd think that having the lowest black
of are lower than any time under Barack
Obama that Obama would say this is great
he can't afford to believe it no Nancy
Pelosi can't afford to believe it Chuck
Schumer can't afford to believe it
because if it was true they would
disappear Mr Speaker we always
appreciate you being with us have a
great weekend we'll see you next week